this is the latest crackdown on press
freedom in hong kong
police arresting the acting chief editor
of pro-democracy stand news
an eyewitness filming patrick lam being
removed from its offices
police attempted to keep people from
filming their raid involving hundreds of
officers
but later confirmed at least six people
had been arrested
hong kong police chief told a news
conference they were detained for
conspiring to publish inflammatory
articles i think the the the primary
concern or the the the number one
concern for us is don't be biased
don't be biased
you you know well how to report how to
be a responsible
reporter how to
how to make a non-biased report to your
readers i know they're talking to
reporter we are not talking the
the media we just target the national
security
law the offenses
if you just won't report i don't think
this is a problem
as well as the arrests of senior staff
at the media outlet former board member
and senior barrister margaret ing was
also detained according to local media
as well as pop star and prominent
activist denise ho
her arrest announced on her social media
account
a subsequent message posted on her
behalf urged friends and supporters not
to worry about her
shortly after the raid on its offices
stand news announced its closure online
saying it had halted operations and all
staff were immediately dismissed
stand news was the most prominent
pro-democracy publication left in hong
kong since the closure of the tabloid
apple daily earlier this year
police charged its former publisher with
sedition on tuesday
sedition is not a crime under hong
kong's national security law imposed by
beijing last year
but this latest raid is adding to
concern the legislation is being used to
stifle freedom of speech anybody who
attempts
to make use of
media work
as a tool
to pursue
their political purpose
or other interests
contravenes the law
particularly
offenses that endanger national security
they are
the evil elements
that
damage press freedom
stand news had already halted
subscriptions and removed opinion pieces
from its website earlier this year now
its raid enclosure adds to growing fears
over press freedoms in hong kong
sally lockwood sky news